[Music]
[Music]
uh let me tell you what's mid sorry uh
this new batman is it mid i've had to
think
you've had a think i've had a thing okay
you've mulled it over mull it over okay
how had a wee think on it i've had a
little i've had a wee thing
what do you think about your life
it's a bit mid
how's my man
edward cullen
i would call him isn't that his name
yeah
oh what's his name in twilight yeah
how's my name robert pattinson as the
batman
so
does he do the voice all right
kind of
all right so first off
[ __ ] horrible thing number one
they use this terrible like nirvana
like i'm a loser song it's like a theme
song
immediately pulls me out of it okay i'm
just like what is this and then it's
just like he's got this emo haircut and
he's like
you know i'm sad my parents are dead
that's like his whole vibe so just it
puts like this weird angle they like
they pop punked it a little bit a little
bit yeah yeah
man i'm such a [ __ ] loser yeah i miss
my parents nah it's like i suck i'm such
a demon my dead parents have turned me
into this monster right right right this
is my legacy
shut the [ __ ] up and write an album man
yeah just sing yeah yeah
yeah
so i that part already was just like ugh
and then
the dialogue
in some scenes is
atrocious
cw level writing right [ __ ] bad
it's like they re like the dude who
plays commissioner gordon is a great
actor that was the dude in westworld
he's done a [ __ ] ton of roles
so good
can you look up his name please
um
uh
jeffrey wright oh yeah he's amazing he's
an incredible actor and they give this
dude
the shittiest lines on earth bro they're
like in a crime scene
i'm actually going to do a dumbass oh
john that he's in severance
uh tatura or that man is in everything
yeah
so
um
this is how inspired i got from this
movie i actually want to make a tick
tock parodying the relationship of
batman and gordon in this film it's so
[ __ ] bad they're like at a crime
scene and
batman
i don't know what happens if it's like
he puts on the mask and his brain gets
squeezed and he loses 10 iq okay he'll
just walk up to things and be like
what is this
and then commissioner gordon has to be
like it's a rat maze
they put rats in it
you know and then like he he's just
telegraphing the plot kyle made a great
call out that i totally forgot andy
circus as [ __ ] alfred there's this
corny ass scene where
uh batman's like you're not my dad
and then andy circus is like i know
you're like well we all know yeah yeah
they don't have to say it again yeah
it's like they made the movie for people
who have never heard of batman
it's like they almost anticipated a
bunch of
10 year olds who like robert pattinson
being flocked to the movie and they're
like well they've never seen batman 10
year olds like robert pattinson like who
liked twilight or maybe discovered
twilight lately he's over 10 years old
well now they're 20. yeah okay like i'm
saying like okay okay
no no there's a bunch of nine-year-olds
in the theater it was just like a
monster truck show
i'm sorry i misspoke but yes it's just
that i think it was like they were
anticipating an audience that had aged
up
so there's just a lot of like really
blunt explanations of things and like
weird cheap reminders like
it just sort of felt like the whole time
they're like well that's cause he's the
batman and his parents are dead and
that's why he's upset uh yeah yeah
you're like okay yeah
and then i will say redeeming parts is
it's the most expressive batman
so what does that mean
like
val kilmer complained about this like
batman his like when you look at it
is like when he puts the mask on it's
very like rigid oh i see you know and
did more like special effects and stuff
so his face has more no it's just like
the mask and like they put a lot of
emphasis on his eyes granted he did the
same look to camera like every time okay
you know it was like this really emo
like
but
you know so the so the mid aspects to me
was like it's just like a little long
little too much hand-holding
and then they had to bring in modern
references and just ruin it with that oh
no
like they the riddler was what'd they
say was like the riddler was a dope
concept and then they like turned him
into like an incel twitch streamer and
you're like
we don't need that we don't [ __ ] need
that
because the raw concept of him as like
the riddler as like this weird smart
nerd i was like this is dope and this
nerd that's like willing to push the and
then they show him live streaming uh
i and i thank you for the bits
basically
like he was one step left of that and
i'm like this is so lame yeah
i was more excited by like one of the
ending scenes than anything
um
yeah just
oh and then they had robert pattinson do
his own version of like where is he
and that just felt weird okay i actually
saw a lot of famous scene from dark
knight right yeah
um
i actually thought it was really funny
because i went to twitter afterward and
people were like ben affleck is the best
batman people like how like he's the
only one that's believable they'd just
be [ __ ] all those dudes up yeah
like i didn't believe robert pens and
it could be sucking people out like that
there's no way
oh also his boots are like basically
like gucci or no they're like louie
boots okay
they're like the boots that can i see
pull up the his outfit i want to say it
and then can you pull up the like the lv
boot that every woman in la has
wait the riddler no no batman
the new one just do batman
2022
like yeah
you know
like [ __ ]
he just has like these like um designer
goth boy boots
it's just like
it's like it seems like they kind of try
to turn them into like
they're a pop punk guy like an mgk or
something they
like definitely leaned into trying to
like sexualize this dude based on
modern
um ideas of what an attractive dude is
not just like connecting people to like
robert pattinson like in real life a
little bit okay you know they're like oh
what if we gave him these types of boots
and like stylized in this way you know
whatever he's wearing like distressed
pants it felt that way like it just felt
like he got holes in his pants i damn
near expecting is it cold in here i dare
you expecting him to walk out and like
turn around and his [ __ ] bat cave had
like the off-white logo yeah yeah
that'd be hard
how are you [ __ ] hard yeah he's sick
i'll be so sick so
you know it was like
it it was good but it was just it was
just all right
and it felt way too long
you're probably still gonna watch it no
you should you should they built up all
this tension with him and catwoman
and like they don't even
they don't [ __ ]
spoiler i'm definitely not seeing it now
oh i guess there's a sex scene that they
cut out but
what
why would they cut that out
it was too hot
yeah
i mean
not not that that's a requirement for
the two characters to interact
but like no but what that's
what do you mean that's like part of the
formula
that's kind of what i mean is i'm like
all right if we're like it's batman it's
trophy romance in there too
yeah
this r yeah but it's like everything
just kind of feels like a blue ball yeah
which i think is kind of batman's whole
existence anyway yeah totally the video
that the movie is very on it feels like
you're watching a comic book
it's it's very
tonally and visually they [ __ ] nailed
it okay really sick
um
so you know that [ __ ] was cool
um
well obviously the batmobile
the sickest part of the whole thing
literally the sickest part of the whole
thing
[ __ ] v14 turbine engine wherever the
[ __ ] that was i don't know but i want it
if robert pattinson knew how to use it
yeah honestly i didn't think like an
idiot
should have cast him i was in there yeah
dude i wouldn't i wouldn't stand for the
[ __ ] yeah exactly
as soon as catwoman stalled that thing
as soon as catwoman would have just
started like
giving me the [ __ ] i would have said
nah
i just can't hear you over the
engine can't hear your [ __ ] over the
engine yeah
um
wait sorry one last scene
like this is like to me the highlight of
the dialogue in the movie so the bat the
bat logo goes up in the sky
it's like weirdly regular
commissioner gordon pulls up in his cop
car and then batman shows up
in his [ __ ]
which by the way
how is he the scary ass dark knight he's
in the loudest most obnoxious [ __ ] like
criminals don't go there he goes yeah
shouldn't it be an eevee nowadays no
like this [ __ ] is in like a hoonigan
like drift mobile yeah
one of one car yeah
you could hear a [ __ ] batman coming
down the street yeah so like whatever
they meet
the the light is hosted in a
construction site so batman pulls up and
it's [ __ ]
he gets up the [ __ ] car commissioner
gordon's like
you didn't turn on the light
and then batman's like i thought you did
and then they go up and it's like
this weirdly regular thing okay and that
to me just like it's supposed to be
funny
i don't it didn't feel like that to me
was like the underscore on the whole
thing right you just have all these
moments where they're like does anyone
know what's going on in this story it's
a blooper but they're like yeah
humanizes it leave it in yeah
yeah
so but go watch it yeah i'm gonna go
watch it um give a solid one out of ten
you